LOBBYING TO MAKE SURE THAT GUYS
WHO BEAT UP THEIR GIRLFRIENDS
ARE ABLE TO BUY GUNS.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN NEARLY
THREE DECADES --
>> AN AMENDMENT IS AGREED TO.
>> -- CONGRESS HAS PASSED A
MAJOR GUN SAFETY BILL WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
>> I WOULD ARGUE IT WILL SAVE
THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
>> WE'RE CONSIDERING A
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT WILL MAKE
OUR COUNTRY SAFER WITHOUT MAKING
IT ANY LESS FREE.
THIS IS THE SWEET SPOT.
>> THE COMPROMISE PACKAGE DOES
NOT INCLUDE ALL THE BROAD
MEASURES DEMOCRATS SOUGHT, BUT
IT DOES INCLUDE A VARIETY OF
SIGNIFICANT STEPS, FROM
INCREASED FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH, TO MORE COMPREHENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR 18 TO
21-YEAR-OLDS.
AND IT INCLUDES ONE KEY
PROVISION THAT ALMOST TANKED THE
WHOLE DEAL.
>> OPERATING UNDER THE BOYFRIEND
LOOPHOLE.
>> THE SO-CALLED BOYFRIEND
LOOPHOLE CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
BOYFRIEND LOOPHOLE.
>> CLOSING THE BOYFRIEND
LOOPHOLE.
A LONG STANDING GOAL OF
ADVOCATES FOR DOMESTIC ABUSE
VICTIMS.
>> THE BOYFRIEND LOOPHOLE IS A
GAP IN FEDERAL LAW.
>> A GAP BECAUSE RIGHT NOW,
FEDERAL LAW ONLY BANS DOMESTIC
ABUSERS FROM BUYING OR OWNING
GUNS IF THEY WERE CONVICTED OF
ABUSE OF A PARENT, SPOUSE,
SOMEONE WITH WHOM THEY SHARE A
KIELD, OR A SIGNIFICANT OTHER
THEY WERE LIVING WITH AT THE
TIME.
WHAT ABOUT ABUSING RELATIONSHIPS
WHERE THE COUPLE IS DATING BUT
DO NOT FIT INTO THOSE OTHER
CLASSIFICATIONS?
ACCORDING TO THE JOHNS HOPKINS
CENTER FOR GUN VIOLENCE
SOLUTIONS, PARTNER HOMICIDES
DROPPED 13% WHEN PROTECTIVE
ORDERS COVER DATING PARTNERS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY DOMESTIC ABUSER, WHETHER
IT BE A SPOUSE OR A BOYFRIEND,
HAS THEIR GUNS TAKEN AWAY.
>> YET, DESPITE THE FACT
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND MORE THAN
HALF THE GUNMAN WHO COMMITTED
MASS SHOOTINGS BETWEEN 2014 AND
2019 EITHER KILLED AN INTIMATE
PARTNER OR FAMILY MEMBER OR HAD
A HISTORY OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
HAS LOBBIED FOR YEARS AGAINST
CLOSING THAT LOOPHOLE.
ARGUING THAT THE MOVE, QUOTE, IS
EXPLOITING REAL PROBLEMS LIKE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO
OPPORTUNISTICALLY TARGET CIVIL
RIGHTS LIKE THE SECOND AMENDMENT
AND CONSTITUTIONAL DUE PROCESS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
PEOPLE WHO BEAT UP THEIR
GIRLFRIENDS HAVE LOBBYISTS
FIGHTING TO PRESERVE THEIR
ABILITY TO BUY GUNS.
AND GUN SAFETY ADVOCATES SAY THE
NRA'S DUE PROCESS ARGUMENT IS A
MOOT POINT UNDER THE NEW BILL.
>> THIS BILL GOES OUT OF ITS WAY
TO INSURE THAT DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS ARE INCLUDED.
>> SO WITH THIS NEWLY PASSED
BILL, IS THE BOYFRIEND LOOPHOLE
FINALLY CLOSED?
NO, IT IS NOT.
>> THEY WENT A LONG WAY TOWARD
ADDRESSING IT, BUT IT ONLY
INCLUDES PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A MISDEMEANOR CRIME
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
>> SO DOMESTIC ABUSERS OF A
GIRLFRIEND OR BOYFRIEND WILL
ONLY HAVE TO RELINQUISH THEIR
GUNS IF THEY'RE CONVICTED OF A
MISDEMEANOR, WHICH MEANS VICTIMS
WHO HAVE TAKEN ONE OF THE FIRST
STEPS OF GETTING A RESTRAINING
ORDER WILL STILL HAVE TO LIVE
KNOWING THEIR ABUSERS COULD BE
FULLY ARMED.
>> THESE ARE EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
INDIVIDUALS BUT IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
SERVED WITH A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER.
THAT MOMENT WHEN SOMEBODY, A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
GOES TO SEEK A RESTRAINING ORDER
IS OFTEN THE MOST DANGEROUS TIME
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL.
>> AND PERHAPS MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY, THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO FOLKS WHO BEAT THEIR
GIRLFRIENDS AFTER PRESIDENT
BIDEN SIGNS IT INTO LAW.
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BEFORE THAT POINT.
IT DOES NOT APPLY RETROACTIVELY.
AND UNLIKE IN FLORIDA WHERE
ABUSERS HAVE TO PROVE THEY'RE
NOW SAFE AND GOT THEIR ACT
TOGETHER, THIS LAW HAS AN
AUTOMATIC RESTORATION OF ALL
FIREARMS RIGHTS AFTER FIVE YEARS
FOR ONE-TIME OFFENDERS.
ALL OF WHICH IS A WIN FOR THE
NRA.
ACCORDING TO THE LEAD REPUBLICAN
NEGOTIATOR ON THE BILL, TEXAS
SENATOR JOHN CORNYN, WHO TOUTED
THESE LIMITATIONS AND OTHERS TO
A ROOM FULL OF HIS GOP
COLLEAGUES.
MOST OF HIS REPUBLICAN SENATE
COLLEAGUES AND THE GUN GROUPS
LOBBYING FOR THE GIRLFRIEND
BEATERS, THEY STILL OPPOSE THE
BILL ANYWAY.
>> I THINK WE HAVE THREADED THE
NEEDLE IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE RIGHT OF LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS BUT TRIES TO GET AT THE
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM THAT
PRODUCED THIS SHOOTING IN UVALDE
AND HAS PLUSED SIMILAR SHOOTING
ELSEWHERE, AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY WILL SAVE LIVES AND
TO ME THAT'S THE ULTIMATE TEST.
>> SAVING LIVES.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS TRULY
AIMING TO DO, TO PREVENT ANOTHER
SCHOOL SHOOTING OR GROCERY STORE
MASSACRE OR A SENSELESS DEATH OF
A DOMESTIC ABUSE SURVIVOR.
SO WILL IT?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
WHAT REALLY IS A MOMENTOUS
OCCASION AND IT SHOULD NOT BE
DOWNPLAYED, BUT OF COURSE, IN MY
OPINION, THE WORK IS NOT DONE,
AND WE'LL KEEP GOING AND KEEP
FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF THE LOOPHOLES IN OUR GUN LAWS
ARE CLOSED MOVING FORWARD.
>> ACCORDING TO EVERY TOWN FOR
GUN SAFETY, WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
THAT ADVOCATES FOR STRICTER GUN
RESTRICTIONS, 19